I was a government major which means I
had to write a lot of papers now when a
normal student writes a paper they might
spread the work out a little late man
wouldn't it be nice hello dr. Mike yes I
kill of our shops key right
yes mask who's calling hey Mike it's Ted
Ted who Ted did I stutter
ted conference ideas worth spreading
talking on stage is smart people stuff
we're calling to see if you want to do a
speech with us yes dr. Mike talk oh yes
yes yes yes
sorry um are you the Ted you're the guy
that started the whole thing you're Ted
good good
hey Mike my name is Bill I work for Ted
Ted is an acronym it stands for
technology okay
say no more bill let's make this happen
you just name the time and place
[Music]
jack-jack hold me jack don't let go Jack
I'm just kidding guys we're Monaco and
it's time for my TED talk I just almost
felt it through all right so I'm getting
ready to rehearse my TED talk there's
people on stage right now you could see
that they're they're practicing their
speeches basically they're asking people
to do one minute of their speech to do a
soundcheck
I'm gonna do my intro and because no one
else even the director assistant has
heard my speech before I'm really
excited to give it to them being such a
huge fan of the TED conference to get a
call and an invitation to speak at a
conference was just incredible I mean
there's so much that I want to say I've
been put in this unique situation where
in between medicine and marketing and
YouTube and all of this stuff I feel
like there's a lot that I want to tell
you guys and I think this TED talk is
gonna be the first step of you truly
understanding what's inside my mind when
I see what's going on in the current
state of media and the current state of
healthcare
all right so we just crushed the
one-minute opening rehearsal which
doesn't say much because the speeches
are gonna be about 10 minutes long but
what I'm gonna do now walking back to my
hotel from the forum I'm gonna practice
my speech right here out in the open
we're just a beautiful Mediterranean Sea
as my audience come 2017 we're saying an
extent
all righty so we just got up it's pretty
early considering as five hours about
six hours back in New York but I'm gonna
lead all the TEDx speakers in a morning
exercise session because you know that's
what I do
[Music]
every time you're swimming this is how
you swim when you can pretend this
[Music]
thirty seconds come on pretty boy
[Music]
it's alleged that you're working on hey
20 seconds in halfway there
3 2 what have breakfast and then it's
time to spread your ideas thanks for
coming I'm a little out of shape so I
didn't go that well but we had fun I
think and we learned something you know
medical side such a nice day Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
okay enough of this you hopefully came
here to see my TED talk well I hope you
did so without further ado roll the tape
do you want you to say that there is a
doctor in the house dr. Mike hi Ted hey
Mike it's bill look you can't play that
speech what it's my speech no but it's
our speech go ahead and link that bad
boy
fine guys just click above
[Music]
[Applause]
I did my
[Music]